at least 70 people were killed in an
airstrike on a prison run by houthi
rebels in yemen on friday the recent
escalation of conflict in the region has
drawn condemnation from the u.n
destroyed beyond recognition
hours after the airstrike rescue workers
are still pulling people out of the
ruins of this detention center in the
city of sardar
and sending them to hospitals
the health service is unable to look
after these large numbers of patients we
are talking about 200 or admitted to
sardar hospitals in one go
they can't accommodate these injured
people
these people are victims of an
intensified conflict between the
government led by the houthi rebels and
a saudi-led coalition which attempts to
restore yemen's internationally
recognized administration
earlier in the week the houthis claimed
an attack in the united arab emirates a
member of the alliance
it was followed by saudi airstrikes in
the yemeni capital of sanaa
and then the prison in sardar
the escalation was condemned by the u.n
any bombardment
that targets civilians
on the or that is not careful enough to
protect civilians is of course also
unacceptable this escalation needs to
stop
following the latest airstrike the
coalition says the houthis had not
reported the detention center as needing
protection
yemen's years-long conflict has claimed
more than 130 000 lives
and civilians are often among those who
suffer the most
yemeni journalist mohammed al-khalisi is
joining me now by telephone from cairo
hello mohammed tell us more about the
situation in saada after the bombings
hi thank you for having me
actually according to
some human and aid organization working
in yemen
around a hundred people have been
killed and injured after us orderly
coalition
attacks prison on
enfada province on friday
some news uh confirmed that more than 60
people have been killed
and also inside this prison there was a
freak african immigrants
yeah so
why will the saudi-led coalition bomb a
prison
um actually the
discussion uh
we need to ask
to ask many times but the quotient
denied uh this target
this target and they said uh this wasn't
recorded and they're uh structured
airstrikes
uh also uh some human organization in
yemen um
uh saying that um
the the caution has attacked this prison
actually we need to ask a
question that why uh this audi koshing
is continuing to pumping um severely in
cities
um after seven years uh they didn't
achieve anything
only
innocent civilians are
being
affected by this
bombing
as we know many people have been
killed and we're running out of foil and
food and you heard about
the
internet uh what happened two days ago
after uh
there was an easter egg sonal
provence
okay yeah we we definitely have been
following on that uh quickly on this one
do you expect the conflicts to intensify
even further
um we are watching
witnessing a huge escalation from all
sides
and same pieces far away
but uh some political resources saying
that uh
the peace talks will be resumed very
like in future soon in future and what
is happening now that all sides trying
all sides trying to
advance on the ground
uh and
you know
all these civilians and civilians we
will keep today not being affected by
this war
okay
yeah yemenis are
most of the yemenis are calling to
stop this war and actually to make a
limit for this
humanitarian crisis
okay journalist mohammed al-khalisi
thank you
thank you so much
you